good evening I'm former United States
Senator and recidivist presidential
candidate Mike Gravel out of common
decency and a court order I'm obliged to
warn you that the 3d reason dot TV
videos you're about to view are not only
terrifying but real members of the
audience who are susceptible to seizures
high blood pressure and politically
induced rage should exit their browsers
now children pregnant women and fiscally
responsible adults should consult an
accountant before watching these videos
if you feel your head is about to
explode at any time you may obtain
immediate relief by screaming don't be
embarrassed to open your mouth and let
it rip with all you've got remember a
scream at the right moment just might
save your life and your country's future
i'm nick gillespie of Reason TV and I
want to tell you a tale more terrifying
than Rahm Emanuel in a locker room
shower gaze deeply if you dare since
World War two federal revenue is
averaged right around eighteen percent
of gross domestic product despite all
attempts to jack it up through the roof
or cut it down to size yet federal
spending has grown more sharply than Al
Gore during a full body massage rising
from sixteen percent of GDP in 1952
almost twenty-six percent this year and
spending is projected to be well over
twenty percent of GDP for the
foreseeable the tragic result the
federal government's balance sheet is in
a hole deeper than John Boehner Stan
i'm nick gillespie of Reason TV and I've
got a story spookier than Harry Reid
guest starring in The Vagina Monologues
look upon this balance sheet from Hell
in 2009 the federal deficit was a
record-setting 1.4 trillion dollars for
over twelve percent of GDP the highest
level since World War 2 2010 in 2011
will match or beat that meaning that in
just three short years the federal
government will have bled more red ink
than Tiger Woods during his divorce
settlement the federal debt which is
made up of all annual deficits plus
interest on borrowed money is around
forty-five percent of GDP and is
projected to be ninety percent by 2020
which means that the government will be
sucking up more and more of your money
tomorrow just to pay for bailing out
citigroup and GM today
it's just like a chevy cobalt a living
death on the installment plan
i'm nick gillespie of reason TV and i
want to tell you a tale more frightening
the michelle obama at a fat farm chew on
this if you can in more than 8 of 10
occupations federal workers make more in
straight salary than their private
sector counterparts and they average
about four times as much in other
benefits such as health care and
pensions a federal janitor makes six
thousand dollars more than his private
sector counterpart and a federal nurse
makes eleven thousand dollars more than
her counterpart at the state local level
public sector workers do pretty well too
in michigan for instance public sector
workers make about forty seven percent
more in total compensation than private
sector working stiffs while taxpayer
budgets are stretched tighter than nancy
pelosi's eyebrows public payrolls are
looser than joe biden's lips